obviously one of the potential scenarios
that you could see Happening Here is
that a woman gets into a relationship
with a guy while she's on birth control
comes off birth control and finds that
the dreamy relationship maybe she's
coming off birth control because they're
about to be married maybe they've got
married and they're now going to try for
a child and they haven't been together
while she's been off birth control
before
and she finds out that the dream
relationship she was in might not be
quite as attuned to what she wanted or
was attracted to so I can imagine that
going off birth control can cause
a lot of turmoil within relationships
yeah possibly you know and that's a
really provocative idea and it's one
that researchers have begun to explore
and they found some sort of mixed
results on this but um one of the most
uh sort of carefully done of these
studies was one that was a longitudinal
study in married couples and they looked
at that very question like like what
happens when you have a married couple
and uh and the part in the the partners
met when the woman was on hormonal birth
control and now she goes off of it and
what they found was that when when the
women discontinued hormonal birth
control it did lead to changes in sexual
and relationship satisfaction within the
within the dyad and the women reported
um changes in both of those things but
it turns out whether it made that worse
or made it better depended on how
attractive her husband was and so what
they found is that for women who were
partnered to really attractive men when
they went off of hormonal birth control
they reported an increase in their
sexual desire and an increase in their
attraction to their partner and that's
exactly what you'd expect estrogen to do
it's like all of a sudden estrogen is
back on the scene it's like oh my gosh
like here's my libido and and sex and
this is wonderful and hooray
um but for women who are partnered with
less attractive men what they found was
the opposite and that was that they
reported a decrease in relationship
satisfaction and a decrease in sexual
satisfaction and sexual desire in their
relationship so women who have been
using the more objective tangible
metrics of success in order to judge
their partner may have discounted more
so the masculinity in the way that they
look but that doesn't necessarily mean
that they haven't got with a guy that is
very masculine and very attractive it
just means that they haven't prioritized
that they then come out of this
hormone-induced stupor and then on the
other side of that they go oh holy [ __ ]
I'm actually in a relationship with a
really attractive guy look at how
advantageous that is and now I can have
loads and loads sex obviously I'm being
like exaggerating and also the same
thing happens on the other side what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]